hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to fatal frame to now
when we last left off we had a bit of a
problem that didn't really need to be a
problem but then again I'm a big dumb
doofy Doo and I couldn't get around the
stupid lady that was a big problem to me
where is she a man I actually don't know
a lot of people in the comments were
saying but I wasn't able to identify if
that ghost a 21-point was one thing or
another
oh oh it's delightful in here the door
is stuck fast you didn't even try to
open it why not move your noodle arms
the next time you're gonna do something
alright it's alright way finally found
the creepy house oh I know I found that
in the beginning of the game what is
this and how did I get here I like moved
from one building straight to another
unless I'm somehow still in the same
building I was I don't know why the
music is kicking up like that it doesn't
need to happen type 61 foot oh oh that
sounds very good people are mentioning
also that the type of film does increase
damage as I discovered later on but I do
have an unlimited film supply in type 7
people were often encouraging me to use
that type over constantly using type 14
however I am playing this game how dare
you try to insult my expert proneness I
shall do whatever I def 10 please and if
I search everything I should be able to
find as much as I need right I forgot
thump was telling me that I'm wrong and
I need to change that ah I'm going to
type 7 bill okay alright that was easy
there we go alright all done that wasn't
so hard now was it okay what I'm gonna
do is I was just joking with you guys I
was just playing long you know not
really totally serious I didn't read
that at all wow you guys provide ample
distraction for what I'm supposed to be
paying attention to in the game even
though I'm sitting in this room alone
alone and with nothing else to worry
about I really don't know if there's
anything in this area that I'm actually
supposed to find that's important of the
story because thus far everything that's
needed to be found has been glowing even
like sick walk
who's the ghost who's ghosty huh find
the sheet huh
there's a faint I got a faint blue glow
on my filament uh okay I can't tell if
it's that lighter if it's something else
what is going on here hooray then
pretend like nothing happened okay it's
getting real serious now it's behind the
curtain isn't it I mean it looks like
it's not gonna be a dangerous ghost it
looks like it's gonna be uh why oh hey
there oh hey ghosty go I see you there
don't try to get close to you BAM gosh
you go get away from me oh oh oh I know
that place it wouldn't let me in that
place before what do I gotta go back now
and find the bloody room and the bloody
ghosts and the bloody ghosts go stab me
with blood make me bleed all my blood
all over the floor no I love my blood
darlin don't make me bleed my blood okay
no one makes me bleed my own blood
what I don't know if that was bugging
out in the gamer the emulator if that
was ex supposed to be there was a little
bit of horribly woo in her voice okay
there's a lock engraved with a diamond
stack pattern family crest on the door
the key is covered with a dark red
substance blood
oh no the blood ghost was already here
everybody run for your bloody lives
everybody run for your blood I think
that's actually a charity run probably I
think is that I I want to say that's a
charity for leukemia I'm not sure though
probably totally inappropriate to joke
about that to everything alright
okay all right then okay
all right I guess I'm going back but
that means I gotta go back through the
way that the lady was or manner thing I
don't know so am I gonna be able to
fight it there come from this door huh
okay I think this is the house to the
distorted audio because I need to get
out of here
they're good up to this point I'll just
save and go back then I'll go back all
right
back to the lady that made this all a
giant problem way way way not long ago
yes yes I know I know I know I'm trying
to be as quick about those safes as
possible so it doesn't bother any of you
guys now teddy bosses any of you guys
I'm actually trying to listen to you
guys I'm trying to follow your
directions which is actually kind of
helping me out a lot in this game
because the more I understand it the
more I actually am able to play it
appropriately so they say you guys
wouldn't be too angry with me if I nice
timing on the lightning but that does
not bode well for my not failure down
the road okay
I guess I'm going back she's still here
she's still here ah she still here not
yeah no she's still here
yeah I don't know how this helped me how
did I what am I going to do about you
what ah what what hell what douche what
the douche ah what fresh hell is this
can't go that way it's all blocked up
what am I supposed to do over here in
black and white room land it's not gonna
let me do it I need to do unless it was
another way that I could have gone
mm-hmm
can't see it's too dark where's my
flashlight Network
there's knob back here covered by a
large cloth well why not find what the
object he is maybe I can take a picture
of it damn mmm I see very clear it's
nothing okay moving on
it's gotta be some other way that I can
go hang on I'll be right back all right
mr. mrs. invulnerable terrifying ghost
I'm just gonna grab my rock founder
oh my you oh my oh my you okay how about
that is that gonna stun you so that I
can run by old lady I get it yeah the
Cameo obscure be ever grabbed no effect
oh okay didn't work at all AG I'm a big
dum-dum I'm a big goofy dumb I can't do
anything right whoa type 90 film that
sounds great I got that now so what is
that gonna do for me is the old lady
actually gonna come through the wall
here no she's gonna go out there and
then just block my path Oh
douche
this stupid a hole actually let me go
past Oh finally I just wasn't running
fast enough
oh here I thought my wheezy asthmatic
person was going to be able to run till
it whew
nothing is anything
okay take a picture take a tick take it
[ __ ] you shut up damn it didn't let me
do it here let me do it I tried to pull
up camera wouldn't do it I press it too
many times it went up and away that was
not my fault now that there is anything
wrong with being asthmatic is is that
looping door sounds I thought it'd be
here whoa hey now you're an all star get
your game on
who's there I hear footsteps
all those are mine probably I've got a
blue filament glowy glowy who's doing
them doers oh I see you kind of maybe
aapke door ghost oh i spooked you oh oh
oh oh oh why the [ __ ] laughs I missed oh
god listen dude it says my bode well for
me time to load I got a load up
different different film different not
that not that gotta get an item gotta
get the film ah got type 90 film that's
probably very powerful but I don't know
if I need that I don't want to use my
higher end film yet unless it's for like
a boss or something I hope they're not
creeping up my butt while I'm down
where am i where am i oh oh hey oh
there's soui okay she's up first huh
what's up oh hey hey ah oh come on oh I
got it okay good
that's about safe that wasn't gonna give
me what I needed to get also you'll
notice that I moved my weapon what what
the hell the hell is that do ba hurry
debauchery oh hey that's a little close
to me damn it okay yes yes God why am i
cornered in a tight room sees two ghosts
very inappropriate hey hey god damn it
you suck how do I do the slow-motion
thing I totally forget how to do the
slow-motion thing and I don't have a
time to pause and look up oh really
today today really are these the ones
that like disappeared oh god where where
where where where where where are you
are you pointing me where are you plan
out here I'm out of here I'm out of here
I'm out of here
I'm out of here I'm out I'm Audi
slimming out let me out
hot damn it I gotta use items stupid
stupid stupid stupid stupid I'm talking
about me not them stupid to take the
damn pictures I think nothing no god
really why I'm that letting them breathe
all over me oh stop it with that Szabo's
look gently leaning towards my way it's
not scary
let me get a picture of it real good
picture don't do your Leaney
God why do you have so much health I've
upgraded my camera maybe I need to use a
better one the other ones creeping ugh
god damn it
God Oh Pierson and so I'm so bad
and why am I so bad
ah why did I have to be so bad ah you
better be either cheering for me or
booing me very loudly at this point yes
I got your stupid face you have way too
much health it's not fair
did the other one portal away Oh dad it
portal God why am I dealing with one in
front and one that can portal behind
such a bunch of baloney that's a giant
piece of malarkey portal oh yeah well
they got a better look at you know and
now without is he that wasn't good
enough that that was not good enough
parent without that was not good enough
that was just not in focus yeah that
wasn't following the three the
two-thirds rule I cannot I cannot do
this like Jesus I'm going up going up
I'll save this I'll keep the 61 get
another herbal medicine in me goddamn
these guys is stressful son [ __ ] well
what role is LAN
I got the top of his head
oh that did 65 damn it's barely what was
that I wasn't even ready uh don't do
nothing don't do nothing
still noona awesome they don't do nothin
no one's gonna pop a boob here you write
free oh god I can't get away I can't get
away I'm freaking out
Lou's machine cool yeah whatever I'm
just gonna multi fire you I'm tough Oh
God than only 220 damage yeah no I hear
you play I let the top of your head
again does this make any sense
oh there you are pilot gut ah that was
quite good enough but God so low and
it's not good enough it's so quiet got
your uh let me take a picture why
doesn't he let me when she's in front
ways you're not gonna she's in front
yeah I'm freaking out man
not not okay you're dead you die you're
die good I've run away because lady gone
job lady Gold drop outta me
Sadie go jump where'd lady Sal ad that
lady laughs I don't know why that one I
was leaving clothes why was that one a
good one I was that a good shot I don't
understand the mechanics of this game
enough look at the blast Oh was I
supposed to get that right away oh
they're here ma'am
don't ask me how that works I should
have been going for her first because
she was the one that I really needed to
focus on as opposed to any the other guy
who's a sload whoa whoa I heard that
whoa whoa show yourself all right zippy
dude ah you zippy do not dad zippy do
dad okay there's something on the ground
where the spear used to be okay I'm in
stat key good I need to go buy the big
ghost again all right so there's a lot
of stuff that I need to process after
that fight that was a long endeavor hope
you're all with me on that one because I
was in the middle of a circle adieu
Cherie he's not really my fault
I'm still new to this game a lot of you
a lot of guys out there like I always
get every like playthrough I've ever
done it's funny because you were like
well what the deal I played through this
ten times why don't you know how to do
Italy it's my first time okay be gentle
come on man just have some manners man
apparently man yo man be gentle man my
first time but no this is like I'm
trying here I'm trying my best
what will apologize I panicked let that
the best of me you know I let the stress
of the situation overpower my common
senses
I didn't think properly I'm sweating a
little bit but that's okay because we
all love each other we're all
understanding of our mistakes we can
forgive and forget and then in the next
episode I'll do the exact same thing in
the exact same terrible way and we will
forgive again the cycle continues
everybody the cycle continues sorry okay
so now that all the apologizing is aside
I can go ahead and make fun of more
people and probably be offensive to
someone in some way or some another so
yay that's what I'm all about when I
play video games not togetherness and
unacceptance that's directly what am I
trying to say here
I went from apologizing to making
everyone hate me oh well that's just
what I do I'm just it's just a roller
coaster of emotions at all times but the
wrong roller coaster is like the one you
were very scared of it you thought you
were going on the butterfly ride now now
straight up death coaster straight down
100,000 miles oh man
I should shut okay back to the actual
game we did get the diamond key or
whatever it was trying to say the key
was we got the key to the door in here
now that ghosty thing the big one the
big one that's unkillable and probably
kills me in one hit every time no matter
what I don't know what that I don't know
what the story is behind that one like I
don't know why it exists he/she/it
I don't know I just I want to move on
with my life and I actually wanted whoa
Jesus oh I'm gonna use ha ha uh I'm
trying I'm trying but I'm distracted
because I'm talking to you well you know
a lot to see I'm talking to myself alone
in a room and I'm probably very crazy
maybe I'm hallucinating my entire
channel nothing of this is real maybe on
let's talk about that let's talk about
that ritual if I take oh okay yeah
alright then this is a book where the
spirit used to be like an old diary
ancient village records have been stored
in the ceremony masters house many
discuss the legends folk tales rituals
of the village there are sure to be many
records of folklore and blah the verb in
rituals also called the crimson
sacrifice ritual twins are used to help
seal the gate to hell there are two
parts the visible ceremony which occurs
periodically and if it fails a hidden
ceremony is performed if all the
ceremonies fail the gate to hell will be
open the dead will pour out and the
skies will go dark they call this
disaster the repentance the whereabouts
of munakata z' friends the twin boys
Itsuki and mutsuki are unknown which is
a little troubling if they are found I
might be able to ask them about the
village okay now I'm now I'm regretting
not being able to read the other one
that was in here but I probably can get
to it in my memo
memo I don't know which ones which I
haven't read all these so I don't know
it might have been in the files oh here
we go this is what it would be okay ah
folklorist three I didn't find one two
for several days earthquakes have
increased in frequency at the same time
crimson butterflies are swarming
sometimes blocking out the Sun somehow
they look sad these are all a lot of
assumptions that don't make any sense
villagers then that see them put their
hands together in player prayer the
entire village has an air of impending
doom and the village is quite fearful of
the Earth's fury perhaps crimson
sacrifice ritual is performed to purify
the ground wish you may all right that
custom still remains today oh sorry in
the past every area has some type of
ground purifying ceremony many of these
offered sacrifices to try to calm the
gods if that custom still remains today
it explains the stillness in the village
the twin shrine maidens must be the
Guardian deities of this village the
Guardian deities the twin shrine maidens
have become crimson butterflies and are
returning to the village okay so that's
literally just folklore but the fourth
one there actually seemed to be a lot
less said folklore and seem to be kind
of truthiness in this endeavor that
we're kind of undertaking here but I
should have the key to this next area
hey what are we not gonna talk about
that why are we just gonna accept this
as fact oh okay okay oh okay oh okay you
unlock the door with the diamond stat
key okay
just a random body appears on the floor
in front of you tell you one thing this
game knows how to shut me up
you guys sweating decimas head
that's always had isn't it
my what
you know what happened someone was
calling me telling me to come back and
perform the ritual again the ritual uh
stay with me forever
mm-hmm of course we promise no no for
now no well I'm not okay with this I'm
not on board I guess she was taken away
by demon ghosts for all I know she could
be a demon ghost but good all right fine
whatever is it blood
do you smell all that blood in the air
that way you smell excuse me sorry I
forgot how great it was have your
company here butterfly diary okay min
Munakata and his teacher came to the
village today he said he was worried
about Itsuki and came to help but I
can't tell outsiders about the village
Itsuki's locked up in the storehouse I
doubt he'll be allowed to talk with an
outsider I'll just write all this in my
diary hope no one finds it mr. macabbee
made a picture of us with his picture
box
my face looks strange but it was
interesting to see he's probably going
to be no huh because our cleansing isn't
finished yet before that happens we have
to help him escape if I can become one
with you yeh probably it'll be I'll be
happy that's the only thing that matters
to me say a photo was loose inside the
diary you put the butterfly dairy in
your fail okay yeah so I was right
there's there's a deep-seated connection
okay cameras moving I guess there's a
deep-seated connection between these two
and twins in relation to a ritual of
some type and you know how all that goes
down and creepy statues on the walls
here a great whoa huh picture okay yes I
got you what did it do Oh
something shows in the photo it looks
like the same doll but slightly
different slightly different okay
something the so this is a clue I need
to take a picture of either that doll
that particular that one has this is off
or maybe like you did find a doll and
put it in its place
Oh what about love sorry didn't mean to
do that I don't know why that keeps
happening get out of there get on there
get out of here okay so there was
another doll that was on the outside
they over here I don't know if I need to
pick a baby
oh and that doll would show me the way
to the truth oh the dead body's gone
okay though I've not gone any more I'll
just be on my way
okay why why why why why why take a
picture of you I'll pick you so hard
let me Oh me what are you even doing I
got a head the face frame me Oh sobbing
huh oh yeah what why fatal friend I only
did to 20 damage did you go my film in
OneNote
oh I'm on film type seven why am i in
film taxa god I keep thinking the
triangle is better
hey oh I keep thinking that the triangle
is a back out button when it doesn't
need to be yeah old film low power but
it'll be enough to deal with you where
yah where he had old lady hey you're not
gonna get back no I do the slow again
I don't even remember how to do the slow
why is all these buttons pressed to
shoot
what's the slow bun I thought it was a
triangle it's net didn't they tell me
was a triangle man ah you said it back I
got you
that was gotcha that wasn't gotcha
Derek ah [ __ ] okay man that type 7 film
does nothing like nothing
comparatively why you're some grudge
sounds oh there you go up well you stay
away from my sister yeah you stay away
from my sister II yeah alright that's
what we're talking about here I'm at
exorcism Oh bad
okay why did you appear in the middle
you're straight up at out of the
grudging and the ring of the sky okay
why is why is that why is that that like
I don't I need I need to actually look
up things because I'm not 100% on the
mechanics of this goddamn camera I know
that it said I need you to slow whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa quick videos
that ain't supposed to be a thing oh god
damn it
oh I see you I see you you want run at
me again huh
it's pretty me there's you but oh dared
you good oh you go back and fall down
into hell I didn't mean to do that
what god damn it straining me like I
know it's I know it's the camera but
still twin doll heads oh they're old but
beautifully decorated they're probably
the heads for the doll in that other
room
great so I did need that for something
yay I'm happy life is great okay so I
think I need to take a picture of this
again so that it'll thing
okay so I need to do something oh whoops
there we go okay sound came from the
doll stand it seems that inserting their
heads makes the mechanism start to work
here's something the two chosen children
shall he carries a heaven the wings of a
butterfly
oh crap oh crap what how am I supposed
to be able to do this I know what I need
to do I need to get the two orange ones
on the bottom all the way to the top but
I'm not good at puzzles like this I
actually I'm not just plain-old not even
oh I'm running out of time already
already I barely had any time oh I'm
probably looks very bad to everybody
every was like oh your sponge burger gee
did your burger hate you bring it down
hot damn it dot d hey I hate so much I'm
gonna beg it ah
Oh Frank wreck that was not the right
thing to do Oh sassafras get psycho
psycho psycho psycho psycho some came
for the small drawer on the dole sand as
if it just unlocked by the most
heart-pounding thing that happened in
this whole game yeah probably when the
ghosts were trying to kill me that
probably berry bad okay something in the
drawer butterfly key a butterfly design
is carved on the wooden key okay
remember there being a butterfly door I
don't remember exactly where it was but
I okay my you you want to lay off of the
death talk you know all the things you
came back from your return trip to hell
like from event horizon you know how you
come back and you're kind of not the
same for that upcoming movie about how
they bring people back to life and
they're not quickly
so anyway I'm assuming that I need to go
back now pass the giant ghost and then
find the butterfly door which is great
all great things all fantastic things
all things I love why is that on the
ground I don't remember that being on
the ground that's not even on the ground
it's on a desk
I'm even more flabbergasted
I didn't check it twin girls of the
house gave me a map that shows a side
door they said that the hidden ceremony
is near and I should escape out the side
door during the night he left so quickly
I couldn't even ask them about it the
other people in the house are acting
normally is there some ulterior motive
behind the generous hospitality just to
be safe I will tell Munakata to go home
ahead of me
alrighty then damn I'm sorry if I skip
pass up it's really like okay enough
with the demon talk talk normally if you
want to talk to me I'm I was like two
steps away there Mayu it's gonna be this
is gonna be an escort mission unlike any
other
come along my you come along my child
Wow you appeared very quickly behind me
I don't know but I know this I got you
BAM
talking man how dare you oh you're the
guy from the flashback not us what not
us what that was a guy who was like the
father to the twins from the flashback
case you're gonna anything popping up I
need to like be at the ready like 24/7
but the problem with me talking over
this crap is that
I'm god damn in my you you are creepy
creepy girl is that I'm not focused 100%
all the time looking at your beautiful
faces out there I can't okay I'm so
distracted but you're just a gorgeous
watch Oh
yes yes yes resume the game because I'm
being trained the triangles are back but
at first you know I actually I'm gonna
cuz I know I know there's got to be like
something about the camera that missin
or maybe those is like ah okay the slow
lens car the slowly well okay
she used press a triangle button when
you charge one or more spirit
powerpoints uh uh but I mean way huh
when I press the triangle button all it
does is take a picture and I'm assuming
the spirit powerpoints there's a thing
in the bottom left that says like a
charge meter or something is a bunch of
baloney get out of my way me oh my you I
don't my name's me Oh your name's my you
would you say would you say me your back
says I will get you ma'am I got you
calling man even though you're kind of
similar to talking man they're cool Luke
okay so I don't know what it means I
don't know what the my deal is I don't
know what's going on I need to know is I
need to get away from this lady or man
or thing or it that's in here demon Oh
cutscene oh hi
my my you know don't be a goofball now
come back nah there's a ghost
oh no okay
that's not my you that is not my you
back away slowly
hi okay
Mayon what's wrong Oh
oh nothing oh oh nothing oh why didn't
you tell me sooner there was nothing I
could have gone off to nothing'll and
got some more nothing for us I didn't
hear what you said there was no
subtitles during that time so I'm gonna
pretend like I didn't hear anything in
them you need to stop saying creepy [ __ ]
behind my back so I can actually focus
on what's doing I'm guessing the why am
I going that way because of the game
developer Wow no why no oh no and I
wasted precious I could it really
disturbs me that I can hear it just as
clearly as ever when they're like when
I'm in the menu and when I'm not he's
it's just the one just one blast you
back I'm gonna I'm gonna use triangle
this time I'm gonna press triangle first
oh my god yeah okay
oh oh I get it okay it never made sense
before because I thought I was taking a
picture but no triangle oh it puts like
an effect on them but that doesn't even
make sense
oh I goofed if you've tired well back up
back up I can trigger make up for it
dary Akasha for summer supposed to like
flip in and out like that like why can't
it be just a consistent thing I'll get
you ah I got you you're making this
difficult for me but not something I'm
gonna ever like get distracted by this
it's the way the game is I know it is
I'm gonna play by your rules
yeah will you will you be beat will you
be no not my scares no no I'm just a big
pile of nothing
why are you I'm just a big nothing can I
still go round the Sun feel free
oh yeah you'll leave that bow oh no no
my no no leave her alone how dare you
why these guys have so much health need
for oh hi my you yeah yeah I would love
to take your picture oh oh I didn't know
this was a you thing oh well I didn't
know he was a close
he's almost admire zone panic so I will
silver the travesty oh okay my you just
gonna be in all the pictures photo
bombing me that's okay I guess
Pam oh it's all like it's okay he's only
like inches from your face oh one good
for me alright my you you feel good
about yourself my you you feel good oh
don't you doll don't you sass me my you
huh mom and dad are here mom and dad are
gonna protect you anymore
I can sock you in the back of my hand
are you a known to know huh I got the
camera what yeah
Aaron died just a little sisterly love
Galu yeah well give me that whatever
this is is ghostly ectoplasm hmm Oh
spirit orb that's what I needed I needed
that upgrade alright all frayed now
because that's a good choice I'd be good
mm-hmm okay so
um I already have that I already have
the functions and features I just need
to power up this scrap okay so I need to
add spirit arms arms arms spirit arms
okay so if I do maybe a little bit more
range would be good because for some
reason it's very finicky BAM oh oh how
did I how when did I get all those
spirit orbs I didn't I know that I had
that many okay um okay that door needs
to shut okay uh there's a draught blown
in feel cold I'm very uncomfortable yay
upgrade hey I'm great oh boy so the
reason why you guys wanted me to take
pictures of the random ghosts because
they give points and points are needed
upgrade so I need as many points as
possible that's why it was probably a
bad idea to actually run away from the
other ghosts okay so where was the
butterfly door I don't recall there's a
safe point out there probably best it
would behoove me to go back to the that
way that's the only way I can go though
so let's just go that way all right come
along my you
are you what did I say about all that
talk that you need to not be shouting in
my ear oh yes we were born for this
purpose I was born to shut you up
I was born to get out alive
oh here what do you have oh that's right
there's a butterfly Buble I don't know
but I'm gonna take your picture
Oh why is it not on him did he go
already like no time Hermes man yer a
mess Yammer all right use the butterfly
unlocker with the butterfly key I'm
guessing the logic behind this is that
little girls weren't be able to bash
down doors whenever they need to
oh look something in the ceiling my you
go upstairs and jump and get it feel
free Kerbal Madison all sorts of goodies
just lying to you today excuse me very
much I'm sorry apology i define
absolutely not
oh I get ya child at the door what are
you doing here little child collect your
mommy there you place for you yeah
you're creepy thanks for rubbing in the
door for me there gonna be some goodies
in here I'll steal all your candy oh
you're years and years old kid yeah I
gotcha oh I did it I got that one oh
yeah I feel good about myself I wonder
if the slow function works on them I
mean if it does I might as well just
take their picture as opposed to doing
anything else at 14 film alright alright
alright alright let's see with a little
kid wet all right I'll read oh boy what
talk to me or stuck fast it's stuck with
all this goopy goo yeah I don't know
where it came from
yeah it's alright I got it Oh
thousand dollars a quick one I don't
know who could have gotten that one jeez
it's a bunch of baloney yeah just follow
me my oh just rub your face all over
those dirty claws is this law engraved
with a diamond link pattern family crest
on it
good for all these families like no
great I'm so happy for them being able
to live their amazing lives
owning doors why everyone wanted so
happy our family just has capital on
nightmares
we got a monopoly on that [ __ ] don't try
to land on ours you'll get run out of
business
kimono hanging why your kimonos hanging
on the walls
isn't that something that's not supposed
to be on the walls is that like that the
some culture that puts rugs on walls and
that's something that I don't get but I
don't know who does that like like I'm
not questioning it like it's totally
know if you will throw your rugs on the
walls
feel free I ain't gonna judge you for
your rug Wallen I'm just like I don't do
this is me something good reflecting
light yay I got more 14 film people are
gonna be so happy I'm not wasting things
all I'm doing is I'm running around
spamming the use button that's about the
best I can hope for yeah I know I saw it
first my you don't try to take credit
for that car the flu buggy came over on
the spider web strung across oh oh
that spider web oh that's vividly clear
every time you talk I am creeped out
okay so how am I supposed to get it yeah
let me just get a real good look at that
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] now ah this is a
bunch of baloney ma'am I you go go get
that please please would you be a doll
would you be a dear and flee
thank you did you get it for me
sometimes I don't know if that's like a
flash like I think it's a cutscene
happening and that's why I hesitate
sometimes did I get it
you're good I know it's over there I
know there is what do you want me to do
about it not like I can pick up this
candlestick over here and go grab it
Kenan
it's not like that would be okay I know
very well it's over there I really hope
that it's just gonna make me go
an outsider visited with perfect timing
I'll use him for the hidden ceremony and
pacify the plur we must ensure he
doesn't escape before that that's all
for now that's all I wanted to write
down to my journal of craziness all my
psychotic ramblings about how I'm gonna
murder everybody for the ceremony
although I wouldn't be surprised if it
was actually all true and just horribly
happened like this actually is hell
leaking out I can see the feet of a
statue promoter that why am I just
spinning in circles damn it what am I
supposed to do am I supposed to do in a
room with a man again on it virtual Tom
if that dude crumbles on a year without
the ceremonia kasuba kusabi is needed a
kusabi is an outsider made into a Buddha
and offered to the moon the more they
suffer the greater the calming of the
human oh great
right alright great well where does this
lead wait let me check my map here
where's this going oh oh I'm up here
when did I get up here I need to save
anyway so I'm just gonna go over there
and I'm gonna save I guess that's
convenient for me but it doesn't really
make me understand what the hell's going
on
maybe I'll just spend my career of
opening doors exceptionally slowly and
I'll be totally happy in life that's all
I really needed Haim yes okay so I'm all
out of time for this particular episode
I've been recording for about 52 minutes
here and I think I made a bit of
progress even though I'm saving and the
almost exactly the same spot that I
started but I did progress and you all
can document that unless you skipped
forward in the episode if you didn't
really see anything but hey I can't
blame me for that the ending is always
the best part who wouldn't want to skip
to the end so thank you everybody who's
joining me from the
the episode and thank you everybody who
made it all the way to this part can't
wait to play the next one thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next
it was come back here I got some
questions for you take great go for it
6-3 I don't know what